Greece is in trouble
headlines about the nation's financial
troubles have been flying since 2010
across the Atlantic Puerto Rico is
suffering rising debt and a shrinking
economy with a credit rating of triple C
plus the island is sliding toward a
possible default Puerto Rico is a
territory of the United States and
people are beginning to ask is it
America's Greece the short answer is now
Greece has a population of 11 million
owing 360 billion dollars the country
has a relatively large economic
footprint Puerto Rico on the other hand
has a population of only 3.5 million an
outstanding debt of 73 billion it's a
much smaller player in the world economy
what really matters is who is holding
Greece's debt its eurozone neighbors
including Italy France and Germany have
been propping Greece up if Greece
defaults on its loan payments it could
rock the economic stability of countries
across the eurozone and could cause
Greece to leave the euro in Puerto
Rico's case it's mostly hedge funds and
distressed debt buyers who hold the
islands debt and if the territory
defaults they'll lose money the United
States government has much less of a
reason to get financially involved in
Puerto Rico than the eurozone countries
do in Greece there is little likelihood
Puerto Rico would leave the dollar
therefore little likelihood of a u.s.
bailout